こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
[音楽]
髪が長いですあの僕基本的に前髪作ってる
人間なんですけどももう前髪に作れない
わけないといけないぐらい今すっげえ
髪の毛伸びてて前髪くん見る
せっかくセットしたのに
もう閉じなくなっちゃった
閉じなくなっちゃってるな前髪作るともう
こんな長さもう全然目しっかり隠れる
くらいかなり今前髪長くても分けないと
仕方ない状態にはいるんですけども
髪の毛切る時って美容室行くじゃないです
かで美容師さんに切ってもらうんです
けれども
お金かかりますよね切ってもらうとそこ
ですと思いました日本で一番高い美容師
さんて誰やいました日本で一番高い美容師
さんちょ今回俺本当に何の情報も入れて
ないんですけどもとりあえず高い金額が
ぶっ込めばかっこよくなれる
そんなちょっと
短絡
なんですけどもとりあえず1回世界一高い
美容師さんに髪の毛やってもらったらどう
なるのかちょっと気になったので今日は
やってもらいたいと思いますまず何の情報
もないんですけどもとりあえず東京という
ことはわかっててでもすでに予約もできて
ます予約取れました世界再び金額は僕は
分かりません
100番だったらどうしよう100万とか
だったらあのちょっとあのー
キャンセルしますさすがにそこまではいか
ないと思うんですけども美容室安いところ
から高いところまですごい幅広いから
ちょっとね日本一高いって言われると
どんなもんなのかどういう仕上がりになる
のか全く未知なんですけどもちょっとこの
私はじめ社長が自分の身を挺して行ってみ
たいと思いますでは行こう
はいというわけで美容室に着きました東京
ですね東京のこちらサロン
峡谷さんって方なんですかね多分この方が
オーナっぽいですね
よろしくお願いしますじゃあちょっと入っ
てみたいと思います
[音楽]
緊張するな
ウェルカムとラグジュアリー空間
社長こんにちは
はいというわけで本日
施術してくださる
京極
龍ですそうです世界史の美容師兵庫龍です
ラジオにいただきましたよろしくお願いし
ます本当に僕勢いで日本一高い美容室調べ
たら
京極さんが出てきてはいそうです日本一
高い美容師ですよろしくお願いしますはい
任してくださいなんかこう
なんで日本に高いんですか
技術とかいろいろあると思うんですけど
そうですねまぁ実際自分自身が23歳の時
で世界一をカットとカラーでロンドンで
世界大会で優勝した実績もあってすごいな
でそこからでもずっと技術を
磨き続けて今閉める88,000円
でも予約が来年の10月までやって
るっていう始め
社長様は日本のYouTubeを
代表する方なのでぜひこのラグジュアリー
イメージをして
日本のYouTube
業界をパーッと爆上げしていただければと
思っておりますはいありがとうございます
お願いします
そこからさらに別に
設置台とか
施術代がかかりますねすごいちょっと最後
のお会計楽しみにしてくださいちょっと
今日はよろしくお願いしますお願いします
なんかめっちゃ部屋かっこいいですね今回
はじめ
社長様はこちらの3で明るい
未来への扉を
開けてください
[拍手]
ここから入ったらもう新しい人生が始まり
ます
ね
[音楽]
全部個室になってます美容
室行くと他の人とかもいると気になっ
ちゃってそうですよね目線があったりとか
気にしちゃいますよ
完全にくつろぎしていただける場所ですね
それはめっちゃありがたいです
改めてお願いしますお願いしますまず気に
なってる
髪の悩みだったりとかヘアスタイル悩みと
かを教えていただけたら前髪が今長くて
ほんとはセンター分けしたくないんですよ
あそうなんですね
でも戦闘機もかっこいいと思いますただ今
ちょっとこっちがボリュームが出てるので
頭大きく感じるんですけど戦闘機も
ちょっとこっちに動きありながらこっちを
抑えるとひし形のシルエットすると結構
小顔効果もありながら顔周りにもこうやっ
て髪の毛を落ちてくるんで全体的な
バランスが良くなりますね
悩みってとそれくらいであとはもう今日奥
さんのお
任せでいいと思います今やっぱり実際に
はじめ社長と一緒に今話ししてすごく
チャーミングで人をこう穏やかな気持ちさ
せる
逆にこう髪色も暖色系とかでもあるかな
ちょっと季節的に春なのでそうですね
なんかちょっとピンクパステルピンク系と
か
長沢正直今もそんなに長くはないので本当
に形をもうちょっと整えて気になるこの
前髪のところの動きを出しながらどっち
かって言うとタラとかで違いを出していく
という世界観の方は絶対いいですよ
ありがとうございます
なんかもう今お話しした感じで
京極さんの人気の理由がちょっと分かり
ましたありがとうございますすごい話し
やすいです
よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
色を抜くということですねはいそうですね
結構ブリーチしてましたよねあの僕も
はじめしゃちょー
ブリーチセルフブリッジの動画を
懐かしい見たことありましてめちゃくちゃ
見ました自分が美容学生
はちょっとやったりとかやってました
やっぱりこの100%のケラチンも入れて
いきます人望100%のケラチンそうです
尋問100%なので
髪の毛と同じ性質ですすごいなんで
ブリーチで色素を抜きながら
髪の毛と同じ性質のケラシー入れてるんで
髪の毛炒めないと同時に頭皮もしみづらく
なりますうわーありがてえ早速はい持って
いきますありがとうございますお願いし
ますわたるラグジュアリータイムを
ラグジュアリー
タイムお願いします
ね
しっかりしてる割と強いというか
毛量が多いタイプな気がしますそうですね
日頃すごく頑張っていらっしゃるんでこの
空間だけでもリラックスしていただければ
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございますこの歴史に残る
イメージの時間に
乾杯ですねありがとうございます
初めてカラーされながら
ありがとうございますバイバイ
[音楽]
見た感じですとすごく色素がはじめ社長の
髪に残留してるので時間かかるコースです
ねどこ出身なんですか僕中国出身です
よ12歳に日本に来たので今16年間日本
にほぼ日本ですね
今までやってきた中で一番クレイジーな
カメラだったりという感じですか髪色でも
いいんですけど半分赤半分青とかあと
てっぺんだけ金で顔周りが黒みたいな今日
はそっち路線でかなりクリエイティブな
一目見たら絶対に
忘れないやつ
どんどんヘアスタイルのイメージが湧いて
きました本当ですか今で確実に言えるのは
もうまずそのてっぺんが黄色で周りが黒
っていうのを1個参考にしてそれで
ちょっとどう組み立てていくかっていう
緊張してきたな緊張してきました絶対に見
たことないような感じにしますかなり
明るくなってきましたねだいぶ来ましたね
はいだいぶ明るくなりましたね今1回目の
ブリッジで1回目1回目今日何回し
ましょうあれで時間をおいてじっくりと
色素を抜いていきますはいじゃあ30分後
イェイ
だいぶ色がうわもうすげえすごい明るく
なったかなり
髪も人生も
ブライト
紙も人生もブライト
色がやっぱここ色入ってたからそうですね
[音楽]
赤オレンジな
感じグレープフルーツのピンク
みたいなこの色のブーツだいぶ痛いと思う
んですけどあんまり痛くなかったです
100%のケラチンブーストが効いてます
これ聞いてるんですねはい普通だったら
全部もう一回練習するんですけど今回は
やるのはデザインカラーなのでここから
ブリーチする箇所を特定して配置すること
で
髪の毛全体的のダメージを抑えますこれで
まずは1回流しますはいじゃあドリーム
ドリームだドリームです
夢の空間をどうぞすっごい
エロっすね
[音楽]
じゃーんはおすごいはじめしゃちょーが
フリース1回目でかなり明るくなりました
ねだいぶ明るいですね
だいぶ明るいですけどですよねさらに
明るくなりますさらに明るく大丈夫お
任せ
先生お願いしますね流してくださいここ
からはどうするんですかここからはまず
カットをして今のボールを調整をしてで
そこからブロッキング
ブロッキングしてセクションニングで実際
にデザインカラーのセクショニングをして
ブリーチするところと
暗くするところを分けます
お願いしますはいまずカットからいきます
ね
[音楽]
カットが始まるカットが始まります
普段はどういう風なスタイリングが多い
ですか何もしなくていい感じというのが
一番嬉しいかもしれないです自然に決まる
感じでしたらやっぱ前髪ちょっと多めだと
どうしてもスタイリングした方がいいなと
思います自然だったらセンターパートか
なーっていう感じなんですよね
だったのか
[音楽]
一旦今まずベースカットを終わらしてこれ
でもう1回デザインカラーの
セクショニングしますねこれで僕の中でも
この部分はこの色この部分はじゃあ
ブリーチしてこの分はクラフトするという
のは全部こう計算して
組み立ててますまずブリーチを塗っていき
ますねはいお願いします
[音楽]
すごい寝てましたちょっと気持ち良すぎて
気持ちいいですよね気持ちよかったです
これで中には明るいところと
暗いところ分けてるんですよさらにその中
でグラデーション
すごいですね人生で一度きりですよこの
スタイルになれるでしょうね全部の
髪の毛を全部分けてるので
なのでもう仕上がったスタイルとしては
すごく全部の色がこう
ブレンドして
綺麗になっていくイメージですなるほど
ありがとうございますはいラグジュアリー
はい今20分おきましたありがとうござい
ますすごいすごい真っ白になってます
かなり
この真っ白のところとあとはこの横は逆に
すごい黒です
本当だカラーとブリーチもう同時進行で
やってます
ねはいありがとうございますはいじゃあ
これで流しますはい
行ってきますレッツゴー
ラグジュアリー
[音楽]
はいというわけで
髪の毛洗い終わりましたありがとうござい
ます
どうなってんのこれ
どうなってるんですか
これも全部暗めで引き締まってますよ
さらにここから仕上げていきます
[音楽]
はいじゃあまずクライマックスの仕上げの
カラーとしては金粉も金粉こちらのカラー
剤に
何かというか
によるラグジュアリー効果ラグジュアリー
体をきれいにすることもできるので非常に
体をより安定していくという効果あります
本当
にほぼ金粉じゃないですか
キラキラ
のレベル超えてるね
お願いしますやばいですやっぱほぼ大丈夫
ですか
[音楽]
ラグジュアリーすごいです
[笑い]
ありがとうございます
金粉まみれ部屋から完成ですまずじゃない
です
シャンプ台で流して
完成ですはいありがとうございます
[音楽]
運命の人と聞きましたお完成しましたはい
完成しましたありがとうございます
はい
321おっぱい
[音楽]
すごい
どうなってんのラグジュアリー
全容が把握できるはじめ
社長ありがとうございます
[音楽]
ありがとうございますはいラグジュアリー
すごいですよマジでかっこよすぎます
ありがとうございます今まで金髪とかをし
てきたことあるんですけども横からも全然
違うしそうですね360度どの角度でも
ラグジュアリーありがとうございます
テーマとかはあったんですか今回ははじめ
社長と一緒に話ししてる中ではじめしゃ
ちょーの人間性がまずすごく優しいのと
表面に関しては最初はちょっともしクール
な人だったらグレー系とかあーなるほど
なるほどはいでやっていこうと思ったん
ですけどやっぱすごい雰囲気がもう
まろやかミルクティーのよ
まろやかな感じなので色もミルクティー
ブロンド
可愛いですよねでこの表面にまずメインで
持ってきてでその陰影というところで男の
深みとしてプラチナシルバーをはい
ちょっとこう間に入れてでさらにこの後ろ
はブルーブラックという色でブルー
ブラックもやっぱすごくかっこいいし
コントラストでやっぱカラーの
ミルフィーユで360度どこ見ても
ラグジュアルというのが今回のテーマです
ありがとうございますすごいめっちゃ
かっこいい
めちゃくちゃかっこいいここあんまりこう
いう髪型したことないんで皆さんの反動が
確かに皆さんの反応ぜひねコメント
欄で残してくれたらはいいやめっちゃ
嬉しいです
お願いします
か
本日はお示していただいてありがとう
ございますありがとうございますはい最高
ですはいそれでは会計の方させていただき
ますはいお願いしますはい本日は指名料金
が88,000円ですねはいであと
ブリーチダイヤモンドブリーチと
尋問キャロス100%のブリッジなので1
回が
3万3万3000円とであのデザイン
カラーデザインカラーで表面とあとはこの
ミドルセクショニング全部合わせると
202020万円あとは
髪質改善のトリートメント
全部させていただいた神栖解除
トリートメントが
5万5万5000円あとカットが1万11
[音楽]
全部で
38万7000円387,000円
[音楽]